after six weeks of nationwide protests
opposition to the citizenship Amendment
Act came before India's Supreme Court on
Wednesday but the groups which filed
petitions against the law were
disappointed with the judge's decision
the Supreme Court the government
everyone knows what's happening in the
country yet the four weeks that was
given to the government was done to
waste time we don't think the people of
India are happy with what the court has
said more than 100 petitions have been
filed with the court which say the
fast-tracking of citizenship to
minorities from three neighboring
countries but not Muslims goes against
India's secular Constitution but the
court itself has been criticized
recently for yielding to government
pressure on some of the most contentious
issues judges ruled last year on India's
most controversial religious site in
1992
Hindu mobs destroyed the 16th century
mosque in Ayodhya sparking riots which
killed more than 2,000 people
despite acknowledging that the mosque's
destruction was unlawful the Supreme
Court allocated the land for the
construction of a Hindu temple while
giving the Muslim community an
alternative piece of land to build a
mosque and of course it was if I'm
allowed to say so at whatever Raziel
cost it was based on the public
sentiments more majority sentiment more
and so-called orchestrated by not
majority sentiment I would like to say
that critics also point to what they say
is the courts in action in
indian-administered Kashmir its leaders
remain detained and the internet is
still cutoff in many places five months
after the government revoked autonomy
the court is yet to rule on whether that
is constitutional it's own calendar
advocate Sanjay Hegde has worked at the
Supreme Court for three decades and says
he's never seen the judiciary under so
much pressure from the government this
is the first government which has been
at the receiving end of the judiciary
before it came to power it was subject
to quite a bit of scrutiny
in individual cases so they know the
power of the judiciary and they set out
to him the judiciary the Supreme Court
has also come under criticism from
within its own ranks with senior judges
questioning the relationship between the
government and the judiciary it's been
two years since four Supreme Court
judges held an unprecedented news
conference to raise the alarm about how
India's highest court was being run they
said then that unless the institution is
preserved democracy won't survive now
protesters again for citizenship law are
scrutinizing the court to see if its
independence has been preserved and as
with puranam al Jazeera New Delhi